[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
Russell's up next in Phoenix Arizona
Russell how can we
help oh yes so thanks for taking my call
how you guys doing uh we're having a
blast what's
up yeah
so uh my question is my wife and I just
recently um got on board with starting
the baby steps and uh so we got our we
just got you know every dollar budget
and created the budget so this going to
be probably the first real month of
budgeting and doing that kind of stuff
on both of us together and so by the end
of this month we should be doing baby
step one of getting our, so I'm trying
to prepare all of our debts for the debt
snowball for baby St
two and the question I have for you guys
is we are in quite a bit of debt um
almost $200,000 in Consumer
Debt and I have three car loans that we
are upside down all three and that is
the main question I'm calling about is
I'm trying to make the plan for how to
get rid of at least two of these cars
but at this point I don't have the extra
to cover the the what I'm under on them
and and and because of my credit and my
you know being so low I'm not able to
get a personal loan for them so I would
have to save up the the the extra so
that's where the kind of the meat of the
question is is so I know I want to get
rid of at least two of these cars I know
how much I would need to save in my debt
snowball should I put the amount I need
to save further up in the debt snowball
like if I need $5,000 to pay off one of
the cars should I put that five grand in
that order because the car I would ow
15,000 I would need five in order to
sell it okay so that's kind of my
question and should I put it saying
should I just kind of pause my debt
snowball make minimum payments while
stacking up the cash needed to get out
from under this
thing well either that or just pretend
those cars are 5,000 and do my de
snowball but instead of my car being at
15,000 in the de snowball I put my car
at 5,000 in the Deb
snowball I think saving as much cash
quickly and getting out of this thing is
going to be your best bet to gain some
traction so tell me what are these cars
How far underwater what do these loans
add up to on these cars yes okay so uh
for so all three
so the smallest one is 15,000 okay then
the next one is 20
27,000 and then the biggest one is
49,000 okay go through those again 15
what is that car worth okay so the 15 is
worth the highest I could probably sell
for on um personal sale
is about 10 grand that's if I can get
like the max of it okay then the next
one is about
23 uh maybe 22
23,000 and the biggest one unfortunately
I bought in the height of car prices
during the pandemic and that's only
worth about 35 to
37,000 okay all right what are the total
payments on between these three
loans uh yeah yeah so smallest is
424 O then
589 and then 1,33 oh boy where are the
TS over
$2,000 in car payments wow man no wonder
you can't breathe and that's not even
all of your debt we still got no what's
the other
debt yeah so the other debt is um
student loans between my wife and I
maybe about 25 to 30,000 I had the
numbers but not in front of me so I
don't remember exactly but so about 2530
for student
loans uh active credit cards maybe about
five and then I have a credit card in
collections for about
nine okay and that's
everything that doesn't feel like it
adds up to
200 yeah I wish I my every dollar bug I
just did it all into every dollar and uh
it seems like there's a big a gaping
hole here where you got some other debt
but so you only need you said thought
you thought about oh solar loan sorry I
have a solar loan for about like about
30 about 40,000 there we go oh boy okay
oh boy yeah sorry yeah man first of
all is there a spending addiction here
as to how you got into you kept buying
all these cars you couldn't afford and
did you roll negative equity into the
next one and the next
one so um that was part of it a part of
was rolling negative equity into the new
cars the other part of it
is a couple years back you know my wife
and I were in a bad spot in our marriage
and she was kind of desperate to find
something to make her happy and she
bought a third car so there was
relationship issues which caused
spending plus just dumb rolling negative
equity into some other vehicles so it
was it was a mixture of both and for the
last year I've been trying to work with
my wife to try to get back on track and
so finally this last month we both
agreed it was harder to convince her but
she finally got on board that's why I'm
calling now is now I'm not okay you're
both on board we're ready what's the
household
income household
income let's see net bringing home is
about uh right under 10 grand 10 grand a
month net yes oh to a month okay so in
your budget how much margin is left
after making all your minimum payments
all $2,000 of car loans plus all the
other debt is there anything left yeah
so as we just did the every doll we just
did the budget and for like this
month we had a couple extra things to do
this month like getting tires for one of
the cars but besides that our normal
what we have left a throw a debt is
between around eight to uh $800 to ,000
a month if we cut back on on what the
need will cut back on you know spend
eating out that kind of thing there's
about $1 to $1,000 a month okay so I I
want to get to something really quick
George he said he he was worried that he
couldn't sell the cars because he
couldn't get a personal loan but and it
doesn't seem like he's got bad credit
you're making payments on all these
things so you probably have a you know
you could go get the uh sell all three
cars and then just consolidate the
difference into one loan from like a
local credit bar well yeah where do you
have all these loans through is it
through one place multiple
places yeah the car loans are multiple
so you know you got Kia finance and you
got Ally and then you have another one
for the third one okay I did already try
because I was already thinking about how
to do this and I did try already to get
a personal loan you need to walk in
there and ask for the manager and say
listen you guys have a bad loan on your
hands and here's what I'm asking you to
do cover the difference and allow me to
take that on as a personal loan because
right now you have a loan out for 15K
and the car is only worth
10 okay and so you need to be real clear
with them that this thing's about to get
repoed or we could solve this if they're
willing to give you the difference so
that you can get out from under
it you and your wife need to show up
with the manager and talk through the
situation and explain exactly what's
going on with these numbers and say
listen we want to get out of this thing
we want to give back this money we need
to get these personal loans done in
order to crawl out from under these
underwater
cars but outside of that the only other
way is to save up the difference and
knock them out one by one and that to me
is going to be your A1 going forward
let's save up four grand let's get out
from the 2 let's save up another 5 grand
let's get out from the 15 and so as you
do that you're going to free up $2,000
worth of payments that we can use to
attack the other day I think you're
working two and three jobs too you need
to up the income yeah you've got to take
what's the $800 you can throw towards
debt and you've got to double that you
guys are selling everything man cut the
cards like crazy no more cards no debt
is off the table we're going to have to
find out another way to do it no more
car loans no more credit cards no more
solar loans no more live in Lita Loca we
had our fun and it about destroyed our
marriage let's try something different
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way a budget for your
life